bonjour bonjour nous sommes le 1er
novembre jour de la toussaint et selon
certaines croyances jour où les âmes des
morts reviennent diables rouges aux
vivants je sens que je vais avoir peur
j'ai choisi de ne pas parler du beau
bordel que son halloween la toussaint la
fête des morts et leurs liens avec le
saman cents parce que c'est un beau
bordel
peut-être une autre fois à la place et
pour fêter cette période d'halloween que
j'aime tant j'ai choisi de parler des
revenants des fantômes et autres
créatures qui n'aurait pas dû sortir de
leur tombe
ça y est je veux être bien sûr le sujet
est très vaste et pourrait durer des
heures avec toutes les légendes locales
recensés j'ai donc choisi de traiter de
quelques aspects des croyances sur les
revenants au fil des siècles et je vous
invite à apporter en commentaires vos
propres légendes complément
d'information histoires qui font peur
sur les rôles un oui enfin pas trop
quand même
lâchez vous
[Musique]
la croyance en des revenants aux
fantômes existent depuis tellement
longtemps qu'on ne peut pas donner de
date mais les termes employés et la
manière dont on pensait que les morts
revenait à changer au fil du temps dans
l'antiquité on parle plutôt de revenants
de l'art des défunts qui seraient privés
du repos éternel
à cette époque on considère que le
revenant à regarder sa matérialité
c'est littéralement un mort qui revient
qu'on peut toucher qui parle qui agit
c'est le cas d'achille qui d'après
l'auteur grec philostrate l'ancien
avaient l'habitude de sortir de son
tombeau la nuit et de retourner se
coucher le matin cette matérialité du
revenant perdure au moins jusqu'au 16e
siècle
on retrouve par exemple dans les pièces
de shakespeare des morts qui jouent des
rôles à part entière impossible de jouer
des tours à ces revenants là rien d
arrêter ni les prières ni les cercles
tracé au sol postaux gros salle aliénor
hougaard le pour les fantômes de ton
époque elle est bizarre de crise tient
aujourd'hui à partir des 11e et 12e
siècle l'église se mêle du culte des
morts et cherche à le remplacer par le
culte des saints - payen c'est aussi
parlé disent que le glissement vers des
morts plus fantomatique ce produit pour
saint-augustin-de-desmaures n'ont pas de
corps ce ne sont que des images qui
apparaissent en songe dans la
littérature clérical les revenants
peuvent aussi être des anges déchus
autorisé par radio va se glisser dans
les cadavres
c'est ça comme ta tête tu nous couvrent
quelque chose non à partir du 12ème
siècle donc le revenant devient rétaux
classe-m une ombre un spectre un fantôme
du latin fantasma qui signifie illusion
vers la fin du 14ème siècle le mot
anglais boost apparaît également pour
les désigner dans la littérature
chrétienne du moyenne
on trouve assez peu de fantôme par
l'église cherche à les faire disparaître
au profit de thé mondovision
par exemple dans l'âtre périlleux très
beau texte du 13ème siècle
glover affronte un diable pour délivrer
une gente dame basse
mais apparemment ce serait en fait un
revenant que l'éclair aurait transformé
il en va de même pour le combat de
mérule contre grain d'aile sorte de
créature malfaisante et démoniaque
doté d'une force surhumaine et qui
aurait en fait été lui aussi un revenant
avant d'être mises à l'écrit cependant
le revenant de leur montant dans le
folklore et croyances populaires surtout
dans les milieux ruraux et dans les pays
germaniques et scandinaves
certains mort disposent d'une force
surhumaine comme grain d'aile par
exemple bien plus importante qu'avant
leur mort à tel point qu'il manque de
faire s'effondrer le toit sur lequel ils
marchent ou courent les boeufs chargeait
de tirer leur corps on peine à se
déplacer
selon certaines croyances germanique ce
qui leur donnerait leurs forces et leurs
cadres
leur force interne les revenants serait
dès lors dans leur âme ne veulent pas
quitter leur corps et continuerait de
l'animé ça explique par exemple qu'on
puisse les tuer parce qu'une fois le
corps détruit le vin ne peut plus est
fixé à linverse ces mêmes croyances dont
la tribu aux sorcières la capacité de
sortir de leur corps elles laisseraient
leur amour flotter librement avant de le
réintégrer
si je vois des sorcières chevauché par
les airs je fais en sorte qu'elle
s'égare sans retrouver leur peau sans
vous trouvez le risque et date de ce nom
dans d'autres sagas nordiques les morts
ne peuvent pas franchir le seuil des
maisons et même si ces revenants dispose
d'un corps certains récits font état de
morts qui s'enfonce dans le sol pour
disparaître ou qui ne laisse pas de
traces dans la neige des tas de légende
existe à leur sujet parfois le mot
rouvre les yeux pour dire ce qu'il a vu
où s'agitent avant d'être inhumé et on
dit que n'a guère pu s'exprimer en verre
il existe des récits ou les revenants
apparaissent pour rappeler les hommes à
la loi c'est le cas de tom crone à une
femme qui devait être inhumé en chemin
ces convoyeurs s'arrête pour passer la
nuit mais un paysan leur refuge
d'hospitalité pendant la nuit tant
condat se relève prépare un repas et
rappelle aux paysans sont de voir
puisque refuser l'hospitalité
convoyeur est alors passible d'une
amende d'autres revenants réagissent au
viol de leur sépulture
on les appelle alors des habitants du
tombeau et la plupart du temps ils
demandent aux pilleurs de prendre leurs
richesses et de les laisser en paix et
enfin jusqu'au 13ème siècle certains
récits parle de revenants ramené par
necromancer les textes sont unanimes ces
morts-là n'aime jamais qu'on les ramène
vous ne faites pas ça chez vous si tous
les morts revenaient systématiquement ce
serait vite le bordel alors quels sont
les mots qui reviennent et pour quelles
raisons
l'église bricolent une explication à
partir de l'invention du purgatoire
expliquant que le revenant ni bon ni
mauvais se trouve dans cette sorte de
prison des morts et peuvent en sortir
occasionnellement mais on a vu
précédemment que le revenant ne datait
pas du christianisme alors qu'en penser
les anciens l'ancien a entendu à audio à
eau dce a dit durant l'antiquité on
pense que les morts continue de vivre un
moment dans leurs tombeaux ne quittent
pas leur corps tout de suite ce qui
explique la période du deuil
ça ne veut pas dire que tous les morts
étaient à craindre les pires étaient des
mauvais morts on exposait palan buste
dans la maison viande par l'epa deux
dames natio mémorial il pouvait s'agir
des mâles mort des personnes assassinées
ou suicider ou mortes sans sépulture on
les appelait les insep ultime les morts
de noyade par exemple pour les criminels
qui n'avaient pas droit à la sépulture
rituel au moyen-age on craint aussi le
retour des enfants avortés non baptisés
des femmes mortes en couches ou peu
après l'accouchement défiance est mort
avant leur mariage des mariés morts le
jour du mariage
tous ces morts avaient en commun d'avoir
raté une étape un rite
laissons donc derrière eux quelque chose
d'inachevé qui pourrait les pousser à
revenir pour autant tous ces morts ne
revenait pas les personnes désagréables
et sociable taciturne était apparemment
le meilleur candidat pour revenir hanter
leur entourage
généralement pour se venger tous ces
morts étaient considérés comme dangereux
car on les accusait aussi de provoquer
des épidémies
au moyen âge dans les pays germaniques
on pensait encore que les maladies
venait des êtres mythologiques comme les
elfes ou l'ena charme pour chevaux
quelle que soit l'aide qui est sur le
cheval celui ci a le pouvoir de le
guérir
mais encore une fois avec la
christianisation et nains les elfes
disparaissent au profit de revenants
malfaisants la dernière raison
principale pour laquelle des revenants
apparaissent et pour annoncer une mort
imminente
ils peuvent aussi avoir un conseil d'une
menace une question ou des remerciements
adressés et revenons m'apparaissait pas
non plus n'importe quand surtout entre
décembre et mars et au moment du
solstice sortait procès leur apparition
survient aussi principalement la nuit et
là où il fait sombre
pour cette raison on entre rarement dans
les maisons pour éclairer et cherchent
plutôt attirer les habitants dehors
enfin il voyage rarement il apparaît
surtout autour de leur domicile sur
leurs terres parfois chez les voisins
mais rarement plus loin forcément du
fait de tous les maux qui sont supposés
apporter leur présence tant à mettre mal
à l'aise alors leurs contemporains met
en place différents rites funéraires
pour éviter leur retour à rome
on a fait parfois des formules sur les
monuments funéraires pour menacer les
violeurs de sépulture ne violaient pas
sa tombe mais mais était super chiante
vous ne voulez pas la rencontre et
convaincant on célébrait également la
fête des carrefours ou comptes italiens
chaque année en hiver on rendait ainsi
hommage à nos l'art du duo l'esstic nous
sommes en profiter pour repousser les
mains c'est marrant parce que j'ai eu
une pensée aussi qui se passait des
choses pas très catholiques dans les
carrefours
on y croisait soit des fantômes soit des
sorcières ou les deux on vous a tout
appris ça t'étonne encore en germanie et
en scandinavie
j'aime les gens de mauvaises moeurs dans
la tour de démarrer ça fait une motte de
tourner comme ça peu de risques qu'ils
en sortent d'autres précautions sont
prises selon les endroits et les époques
comme brûler le cadavre jeté le cadavre
dans un fleuve etc
ces abandons de cadavres attrait charny
sont un premier moyen d'éviter leur
retour par la même idée on retrouve dans
plusieurs cultures le fait de fixer le
corps dans la tombe
dans certains endroits oppose des
pierres sur le corps dans d'autres il
s'agit d'un pieu saluons le mythe du
vampire au passage dans certains
endroits des passants jettent des
pierres sur les tombes et dans le hall
stein une région du sud de l'allemagne
on pose une herse pointe en bas sur les
personnes dont on suspecte qu'elle
pourrait revenir hanter les vivants à
d'autres endroits c'est le cadavre
lui-même qu'on cherche à lier en
attachant par exemple ces deux gros
orteils ou c'est moi lépingle placé sur
le linceul jusqu'au 19ème siècle a
également pour but de l'empêcher de
bouger
enfin c'est bien beau de vouloir
internement dans leur corps mais pour
d'autres mieux valu laisser filer leur
âme le plus vite possible chez nous
quand quelqu'un mourait on ouvrait
toutes les fenêtres et ont fermé tous
les récipients pour que son âme sorte
vite fait et puis il ne reste pas coincé
quelque part
et puis ont veillé le corps pour être
sûr que car esprits sont en panne
pendant la nuit ce serait la tuile et
dès qu'ils étaient partis ont brûlé ses
draps pour éviter qu'ils ne reviennent
s'est couché non parce que c'est
dégueulasse de blizzard aujourd'hui en
tout cas la formule repose en paix
prenait bien tout son sens elle réalise
at il pas ché pas question que le mans
reviennent dans les pays nordiques ont
percé le mur par lequel faisait sortir
le mort de la maison avant de le
reboucher pour éviter qu'ils ne
reviennent par le même chemin
il met aussi en place un chemin réservé
aux morts pour le mener au cimetière
surnommé chemin de l du nom de celle qui
garde le royaume des morts dans la
mythologie nordique en estonie jusqu'au
19ème siècle ce chemin ne doit pas
passer par un chat sinon bonjour la
culture enfin quelques coutumes amusante
à partir du 3ème siècle danemark en
allemagne en place des pièces dans la
bouche du mort il s'agit de la part du
mof un tiers de sa fortune qu'il a droit
de garder mais morts au moins 20 sur qui
le verra pas les réclamer et si l'on
voulait plus il obtient s'étouffer avec
enfin toujours dans les pays scandinaves
il est l usage de passer des chaussures
aux morts ap les chaussures du mort afin
qu'ils deviennent plus facilement l'au
delà dans plusieurs récits on voit les
morts se plaindre d'avoir froid aux
pieds alors nous négligé jamais
l'importance d'une bonne paire de
chaussures
mais bon poule 2 croyances présenté
jusqu'ici concerne ne démord pas très
gentil dans les croyances germanique il
existait aussi des ponts mort qui avait
de nombreuses vertus notamment en terme
de fertilité
par exemple dans l'ordre du monde de se
nourrir on découpe le mois
le noir en quatre morceaux afin de
l'inhumer à différents endroits pour
bien faire pousser les cultures sacré à
zidane toujours prêts à se mettre en
quatre pour les autres mais comme nous
disions en début d'épisode au fil des
siècles le mort perd de sa matérialité
bas revenant à un rôle précis à jouer
annoncé mort imminente ou réparer les
torts voire même répondre de mèze il
serait dû progressivement à un simple
motif littéraire destiné à effrayer
l'électeur et cynthia se vident
également ce sont plus des rues les
rencontres dans des causes plus de
sacrifices ou d'offrandes sur les tombes
et tout ça a ajouté une bonne couche de
christianisation font couler voire
disparaissent des croyances des haricots
blancs mais souffre en fait les frais
[Musique]
une fois encore tout chaud à will always
be bambi fond mais en fait les frais
[Musique]